faire le parcours deux fois une fois au
classement épreuve de poule les deux
meilleurs vont aller en finale haute
dans ce groupe
près de 90 élèves prêts à s'affronter
dans différentes épreuves
des équipes mixtes ou étudiants
martiniquais guadeloupéens aux autres
nationalités sont mélangés
l'objectif étant de permettre à tous de
se rencontrer et d'échanger qu'on est
parti d'un constat c'est que chaque
année on organise des tournois
compétitif donc ce ne sont que des
compétiteurs qui viennent donc c'est
assez exclusif et là on a voulu ouvrir
donc on a une conception un peu plus
larges de la culture sportive et donc
faire également intégré pardon également
des étudiants erasmus des étudiants
guyanais qui sont avec nous des
étudiants qui sont pas forcément sportif
mais qui sont intéressés par la chose du
sport un projet innovant pour ses
premiers jeux de l'université des
antilles qui favorise l'interaction
entre les deux pôles par habitude on
faisait des équipes de martinique contre
des équipes de voile ou et là on amène
mixer cette année en faisant des équipes
martinique et guadeloupe mélanger pour
justement créer encore plus cette unité
non en deux jours là on crée des liens
qui reste très fort très longtemps en
général une opportunité pour se réaliser
à travers le sport on s'est vraiment
l'ouverture en fait à différentes
personnes et à différents jus
différentes activités
ça permet vraiment de voir beaucoup de
choses ce qui est là toute la
cosmopolitan it2 des gens vraiment c'est
ce qui est très intéressant même si
forcément le la performance n'est pas la
même pour tout le monde
le but est vraiment de partager des
choses ensemble même heure les sports
individuels
au final on partage toujours beaucoup de
choses on permet aussi de voir d'abord
d'autres ouvertures sur mais lille de
matinée quand même d'avoir loupé de voir
les différences de voix aussi
les ressemblances et de même d'apprendre
d'autres choses deux hommes disent ici
pour partager notre amour du sport
bon peut-être qu'il est pas partagée de
tous mais on apprend on apprend ça fait
quoi même pas deux jours où nous sommes
mais on apprend les uns des autres
c'est super et voilà pour ces étudiants
bel exemple de coopération entre
l'épaule à l'heure où les tensions sont
vives entre les dirigeants de
l'université des antilles